Donna listening to you I think there's a
special intelligence a different
intelligence that comes from people from
Silicon Valley people who are involved
in technology because one of the things
that you have said to rephrase it is
that you you embrace failure because to
come up with something new it's okay to
fail and to learn from that in a lot of
the philanthropic world that is anathema
it's as if everything you invest in is
supposed to be successful and the idea
that one could be innovative or come up
with multiple strategies is seen as
risky or not the best use of a donor's
funds but it seems that people with your
background tend to embrace a different
view so that you can come up with some
different solutions that have been tried
do you agree with that statement well I
think you embrace failure it's okay to
feel but you don't want to do it too
many times I mean there's a limit and I
think that as long as if you're a
philanthropic organization as long as
you position something as experimental
here we're going to give this a try
here's what we hope to learn from it
here's how we're going to react to what
we learn from it here's what we're
trying to learn whatever then I think
it's perfectly fine to go into that eyes
wide open and say this may work this may
not work I think the mistake is if you
say oh we're sure this is going to work
this is you know absolutely the right
thing to do and we're all set and boom
and then it doesn't work then you've
really reduced your credibility a lot so
it's it's an awful lot about positioning
upfront about humility about
understanding really deeply what you
know and what you don't know i mean you
know right now we have an incredible
technology that we're working on we know
for sure that this is breakthrough
technology this is important stuff we
don't really know how it intersects yet
with user needs so we're working on that
and we know we don't know that so that's
why we're sort of making course
corrections now but being able to
articulate and understand what you know
and what you don't know and being
totally brutally honest with that to
yourself
to your teammates to your investors your
funders is I think incredibly important